It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
正值盛花期，我的业务规模迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢喧闹，我的连接依然强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月只需 35 美元起。这绝对是一个不会常驻的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。需加收税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. What's the last really gross thing you encountered? Was it a cockroach? A dirty diaper? Yesterday's smelly garbage? Most of us are lucky if we go a single day without encountering something we find at least a little revolting. But what does it mean to call something disgusting? The word can describe everything from a putrid smell to our least favorite food to the word moist.
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负荷使用期间不会遭遇数据流量降速。你遇到的上一件非常恶心的事情是什么？是一只蟑螂？一块脏尿布？还是昨天发臭的垃圾？我们大多数人如果能有一天不遇到哪怕让我们觉得有点反感的东西，就已经很幸运了。但是，称某样东西令人作呕究竟意味着什么？这个词可以用来形容从恶臭到我们最讨厌的食物，甚至到“湿润”这个词的所有事物。
Over the past several decades, psychologists have begun to dig into the concept of, disgust, exploring where it comes from, and how many things it can stretch to encompass. So why do we feel disgust? Why are some people more easily disgusted than others? Are babies born with the ability to feel disgust, or does it develop later in life? Is there anything that all humans find disgusting? Why do the foods that we consider disgusting vary so much by culture or even by individual? Why is gross humor funny, at least to some people? And how might understanding disgust help us address some important public health issues. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
在过去的几十年里，心理学家开始深入研究“恶心”这一概念，探索它的来源，以及它能涵盖多少种事物。那么，我们为什么会感到恶心？为什么有些人比其他人更容易感到恶心？婴儿生来就具备感到这种情绪的能力，还是在生命后期才发育出来的？有没有什么东西是全人类都觉得恶心的？为什么我们认为恶心的食物在不同文化甚至不同个人之间会有如此大的差异？为什么低级趣味的笑话很有趣，至少对某些人来说是这样？以及，理解恶心感如何能帮助我们解决一些重要的公共卫生问题。欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Paul Rosen, a professor emeritus of psychology at the University of Pennsylvania and one of the world's leading experts on the psychology of disgust. He's been studying disgust in its many forms since the 1960s. His research has touched on human food choice, the development of food aversions, attitudes toward meat, how disgust carries over to morality, attitudes toward recycled water, and much more. Dr. Rosen has published hundreds of scientific papers and has won many awards for his work, including the American Psychological Association's Distinguished Scientific Contribution Award for 2007.
，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是宾夕法尼亚大学心理学荣休教授保罗·罗赞（Dr. Paul Rosen）博士，他是世界领先的恶心心理学专家之一。自 20 世纪 60 年代以来，他一直在研究各种形式的恶心感。他的研究涉及人类食物的选择、食物厌恶的发展、对肉类的态度、恶心感如何延伸到道德层面、对再生水的态度等等。罗赞博士已发表了数百篇科学论文，并因其工作荣获多项大奖，其中包括美国心理学协会 2007 年杰出科学贡献奖。
Dr. Rossin, thank you for joining me today. Pleasure to be here. Now, before we dig too deeply into some really revolting topics, I want to warn our listeners that we might talk about some things that will gross them out. So if you have a weak stomach, maybe this isn't the episode for you, and you can come back next week. That being said, Dr. Razum, where does disgust come from? Why did we evolve to feel this unpleasant emotion?
罗赞博士，非常感谢您今天能来做客。很高兴来到这里。现在，在我们深入探讨一些真正令人反感的话题之前，我想先警告听众，我们可能会谈到一些让他们感到恶心的事情。所以如果你肠胃虚弱，也许这一期节目并不适合你，你可以下周再来。话虽如此，罗赞博士，恶心感究竟从何而来？为什么我们在进化过程中演化出了这种令人不快的情绪？
We're not really 100% certain how disgust originated in human evolution. It seems to be uniquely human, and it's quite clear that it serves a function, which is to keep us away from microbes, dangerous microbes. Whether that's the reason it was originally adopted, we don't know. Now, are babies born with the ability to feel disgust, or does it develop later in childhood? Well, disgust is not innate, not present at birth. little infants have an innate aversion to bitter tastes and other tastes. And the face that they make to that is similar to the face that we make to disgust. But disgust doesn't appear until maybe three to five years of age.
对于人类进化中恶心感是如何起源的，我们其实并没有 100% 的把握。它似乎是人类独有的，而且很明显它具有某种功能，那就是让我们远离微生物，即危险的微生物。至于这是否是它最初被演化出来的原因，我们不得而知。那么，婴儿生来就具备感到恶心感的能力，还是在童年后期才发育出来的？嗯，恶心感并非先天具有的，并非出生时就存在。小婴儿对苦味和其他味道有一种先天的厌恶。他们对此做出的表情与我们对恶心做出的表情相似。但恶心感直到大约三到五岁时才会出现。
And what are the things that kids at that age are disgusted by? Is there any pattern? You know, it's surprisingly we don't know that well. And the reason is that feces is the universal disgust. It's probably true that toilet training is the experience which makes children their first disgust, which is species. But I think it's because toilet training is itself disgusting that most people don't study it.
那么那个年龄段的孩子会对什么东西感到恶心？有什么规律吗？你知道，出人意料的是，我们对此并不是很了解。原因在于粪便是一种普遍的恶心源。如厕训练很可能是让孩子产生人生第一种恶心感——也就是对粪便的厌恶——的经历。但我想正是因为如厕训练本身令人恶心，所以大多数人才不去研究它。
So there's very little research on toilet training and what actually happens between the mother and the child and the re-dipering and all of this that communicates to the child what a terrible thing this is. You know, there are some things that are gross to other people, but not to ourselves. For instance, I would venture to say that most people don't find their own poop as disgusting as other people do. People pop their own zits, but if they see somebody else do it, they're going to vomit. It's like, yuck. What is the reason for that?
因此，关于如厕训练以及母亲与孩子之间实际发生的互动、换尿布以及所有这些向孩子传达这是一件多么可怕的事情的过程的研究非常少。你知道，有些东西对别人来说很恶心，但对我们自己却不觉得。比如，我敢说，大多数人不会觉得自己的便便像别人的便便那么恶心。人们会挤自己的青春痘，但如果他们看到别人这么做，他们会吐出来。就像，真恶心。这是什么原因？
We don't really know. Now, it's true that your own poop or your own zet, any of your own body waste is less dangerous to you than to other people because you already got that stuff. in you. So that's a functional reason why you might not be as upset about your own body waste as others. And of course, you're living with it. You know, you've got a colon filled with feces and you've got a mouth filled with spit and you sort of live with it. But even then, most people will not drink a glass of water if they spit into it first. So that was something of their own. But as soon as it's out of their body, it's disgusting. Is disgust in emotion, Is it a physical sensation? Is it both?
我们其实并不知道。不过，确实，你自己的便便或你自己的青春痘，你自身的任何排泄物对你自己的危害都比对别人小，因为那些东西本来就在你体内。所以，你可能不会像别人那样对你自己的身体排泄物感到那么苦恼，这是有功能上的原因的。当然，你一直和它们生活在一起。你知道，你的结肠里充满了粪便，你的嘴里充满了口水，某种程度上你就是和它们生活在一起的。但即便如此，大多数人也不会喝一杯自己先吐了口水进去的水。所以那是他们自己的东西。但一旦它离开了他们的身体，它就是恶心的。恶心是一种情绪吗？它是一种身体感觉吗？还是两者皆有？
Well, it is generally considered one of the basic emotions, and that's because it has the features of emotions. It has a facial expression, which you're all familiar with. It has a physiological presentation, which is nausea, and it has a behavior which is withdrawal from the source of disgust. That's like fear or anger or other emotions, and it has some sort of appraisal. That's the other feature of an emotion.
嗯，它通常被认为是一种基本情绪，这是因为它具备情绪的特征。它有一种你我都熟悉的的面部表情，它有一种生理表现，即恶心，它有一种行为，那就是远离恶心源。这就像恐惧、愤怒或其他情绪一样，它某种程度上包含一种评估。那是情绪的另一个特征。
That is so you have to, your mind has to appreciate what it is that's causing it. You said earlier that there's one thing that's universally disgusting and that's feces. Is that the only thing that's universally disgusting to humans? Well, nobody has, again, looked at this carefully across cultures. So it's conceivable that, for example, vomit is also a universal disgust. By the way, one of the important things about disgust is that little infants don't find anything discussed. They don't find feces disgusting. In fact, one function of diapers is to keep them from eating it.
也就是说，你必须，你的大脑必须对导致这种情况的原因进行评估。你刚才说有一种东西是全人类都觉得恶心的，那就是粪便。这是人类唯一普遍觉得恶心的东西吗？嗯，同样没有人跨文化仔细研究过这一点。所以可以想象，例如，呕吐物也可能是一种普遍的恶心源。顺便说一句，关于恶心，重要的一点是，小婴儿并不觉得任何东西恶心。他们不觉得粪便恶心。事实上，尿布的一个作用就是防止他们吃粪便。
And so until toilet training there, they don't seem to have any issue with body weights. So I think that there are probably other body waists that might be discussed. They could probably vomit as one of them. I don't know that anyone's actually looked at that, believe it or not. You mentioned bodily fluids. I mean, some people, and I'm one of them, will faint at the sight of a lot of blood. Can you overcome that sort of disgust?
所以在如厕训练之前，他们似乎对身体排泄物没有任何异议。所以我认为可能还有其他身体排泄物也算是恶心源。呕吐物可能就是其中之一。信不信由你，我不知道是否有人真正研究过这一点。你提到了体液。我的意思是，有些人，我就是其中之一，看到大量的血会晕倒。你能克服那种恶心感吗？
Well, in general, you can overcome any disgust, including feces. But the main reason you do that is because you're exposed to it enough. For example, we've shown that medical students who dissect the cadaver in their medical training originally are very disgusted by the cadaver, but they get used to it. People get used to things that are disgusting that are in their lives all the time. And perhaps one reason you get used to your own feces and saliva less disgusting is that you live with it, you get used to it. So people get accustomed to anything, not just disgust, anything, if you expose them often enough, except maybe extreme pain. You mentioned before that humans seem to be the only animals that feel disgust.
嗯，总的来说，你可以克服任何恶心感，包括粪便。但你这样做的主要原因是你接触它的次数足够多。例如，我们已经证明，医学生在医学培训中解剖尸体时，最初对尸体会感到非常恶心，但他们会习惯。人们会习惯生活中一直存在的恶心事物。也许你对自己的粪便和唾液不那么恶心的一个原因是你和它们生活在一起，你习惯了。所以人们会对任何事情习以为常，不仅仅是恶心，只要你经常接触任何事情，除了极端的疼痛外，都会习惯。你之前提到人类似乎是唯一能感受到恶心的动物。
And I mean, I know, like I walk my dog this morning and I have to watch her because she will eat her own feces and she'll sniff other dogs. butts, they'll sniff hers. You know, they are really into all of that. What about like our closest relatives chimps do they experience disgust or will they do the same thing as, say, my dog? We don't know absolutely for sure, but many primates eat their feces. So that's a start, which would be like human infants, of course. The other thing is there's one feature of disgust that as far as we know no other animal shows. And that is what we call contamination. There's something disgusting touches an edible food. It renders it inedible.
我的意思是，我知道，比如我今天早上遛狗时，我必须看着她，因为她会吃自己的粪便，她会嗅其他狗的屁股，别的狗也会嗅她的。你知道，她们真的很热衷于所有这些。那么像我们最近的亲戚黑猩猩，它们会体验到恶心吗，还是会像我的狗那样做？我们并不能绝对百分之百地确定，但许多灵长类动物会吃自己的粪便。所以这是一个开始，当然这就像人类婴儿一样。另一件事是，恶心有一个特征，就目前所知，没有其他动物表现出来。那就是我们所说的污染。某种恶心的东西接触到了可食用的食物。它就会使食物变得不可食用。
So you think about a cockroach touches your favorite juice, drops in your favorite juice. That's the end of the juice, right? You won't need it. Now, there's no evidence that any animal shows anything like that. So it's a very potent thing about disgust. It can take a pile of delicious food and spoil it with one touch of feces or a cockroach or something. By the way, there's no opposite to disgust. If you take a pile of cockroaches, there's nothing you can touch to it to make it good to eat.
所以你想想，一只蟑螂碰了你最喜欢的果汁，掉进了你最喜欢的果汁里。那果汁就完了，对吧？你不会喝它的。现在，没有证据表明任何动物表现出类似的行为。所以这是关于恶心的一个非常强效的特质。它可以用粪便、蟑螂或其他东西的一触，毁掉一堆美味的食物。顺便说一句，恶心没有反义词。如果你拿来一堆蟑螂，没有什么东西是你可以碰触它一下就能让它变得好吃的。
So it's just the opposite. The disgust is very potent and very negative, and there's no positive equivalent. But I thought I've heard you say that, for example, say Hitler had a sweater. I mean, people wouldn't touch Hitler's sweater because it was contaminated by belonging to him. And no matter what you did, no matter how many times you cleaned it, it's still contaminated, unless, say, Mother Teresa wears it, right? Have you found that? Yes. We found that for most people. And it's, That's what's called positive contamination when Mother Teresa or your favorite rock star or something wears something, it becomes more valuable.
所以情况正好相反。恶心感非常强烈且非常负面，没有任何积极的对应物。但我记得我听你说过，比如希特勒有一件毛衣。我的意思是，人们不会碰希特勒的毛衣，因为它被属于他的东西污染了。无论你做什么，无论你清洗了多少次，它仍然是污染的，除非，比方说，特蕾莎修女穿过它，对吧？你发现过这种情况吗？是的。我们发现大多数人都是这样。这就是所谓的正向污染，当特蕾莎修女或你最喜欢的摇滚明星等人穿过某样东西时，它会变得更有价值。
But it's weaker than the negative. So no one wants to wear Hitler's sweater, but many people don't care about having the sweater of somebody who's a hero of theirs, and the hero is less potent than the evil person. But you can't overwhelm it with enough exposure up to the positive person. We call this negativity dominance, that negative things in general are stronger than positive things. Now, you've done a lot of work around the idea of meat being disgusting. Can we talk about that? I mean, why is meat disgusting as much as we eat a lot of it?
但它比负面污染要弱。所以没有人想穿希特勒的毛衣，但许多人并不介意拥有他们的某个英雄的毛衣，而且英雄的效力不如邪恶的人那么强。但你无法通过对积极人物的充分接触来压倒它。我们称之为“负面偏见”，即负面事物通常比正面事物更强大。现在，你围绕肉类令人恶心这个概念做了很多工作。我们能谈谈这个吗？我的意思是，既然我们吃那么多肉，为什么肉会让人觉得恶心？
Yeah, actually, the question in a way to me really is why do we eat any meat? Because we are, in fact, say, take Americans, we eat cow, pig, maybe lamb, okay, that out of 4,000 mammals, we eat three. And we don't eat most of them. We only eat their muscle. Most people won't eat their liver. Nobody eats their eyeballs. In fact, we reject almost all the meat in the world and consider it disgusting.
是的，实际上，这个问题对我来说真正的问题是：为什么我们还要吃肉？因为我们实际上，比如说美国人，我们吃牛肉、猪肉、也许还有羊肉，好吧，在 4000 种哺乳动物中，我们只吃三种。而且我们不吃大部分动物。我们只吃它们的肌肉。大多数人不会吃它们的肝脏。没有人吃它们的眼球。事实上，我们拒绝了世界上几乎所有的肉类，并认为它们是恶心的。
And there's a small subset which we come to love. So the question really is not why do we find meat disgusting, but rather why do we find a small set of meats very attractive? And do you have not found the answer to that? No, but it is clear that little children, when they start eating meat, don't know where it comes from. I mean, what's disgusting about a piece of meat is that it's a piece of an animal. It's an animal that we generally find disgusting. So it takes a while for kids to realize that this red stuff that they get from the supermarket and cook up is actually a piece of a pig or a cow.
而我们开始喜爱的只是其中的一小部分。所以问题其实不是为什么我们觉得肉类恶心，而是为什么我们觉得一小部分肉类非常有吸引力？你还没有找到答案吗？没有，但很明显，小孩子们在开始吃肉时，并不知道肉是从哪里来的。我的意思是，一块肉恶心的地方在于它是动物的一部分。那是我们通常觉得恶心的动物。所以孩子们需要一段时间才能意识到，他们从超市买来并煮熟的这些红色的东西，实际上是猪或牛身上的一部分。
In fact, my son, when he was about six years old, was eating chicken at the table, which, by the way, has the name chicken. To help her, you think that this is actually from a chicken. And he suddenly said, my God, this is a piece of chicken. I mean, he made that discovery. Now, it's interesting that we don't name most meats by the animal they're from. In Spanish, you say beef is a meat of cow. That's the word for it.
事实上，我儿子在大约六岁时，在餐桌上吃鸡肉，顺便说一句，它就叫鸡肉。为了帮助她，你以为这真的是来自鸡。他突然说：“天哪，这是一块鸡肉。”我的意思是，他有了这个发现。现在，有趣的是，我们大多数肉类并不以它们来自的动物命名。在西班牙语中，你说牛肉就是牛的肉。那是它的词。
But in the English, we say beef, which is not cow. We don't say we're eating cow. We don't say we're eating pig. So that one way of making, distancing from ourselves when the fact that we're eating a piece of what was once a living animal is to change the name. And what about things that are more culturally specific when it comes to food? Why don't we all find the same foods disgusting across cultures and nationalities? Almost all disgusting things are animal products.
但在英语中，我们说 beef（牛肉），它不是 cow（母牛）。我们不说我们在吃牛。我们不说我们在吃猪。所以，当我们吃曾经是活生生动物的一部分时，为了与这种事实保持距离，方法之一就是改变名称。那么，在食物方面更具文化特殊性的东西呢？为什么我们在不同文化和国度中并非都觉得相同的食物恶心？几乎所有令人恶心的东西都是动物产品。
first of all. Very few people are disgusted by asparagus. They may not like it, but they don't call it disgusting. Many Indians are put off by meat. There are hundreds of millions of them are vegetarians. So there is variation within culture for sure. One issue is that certain disgusting things become very desirable. So for example, in the United States, many people, not all likes smelly cheese, which is rotten milk. And that's pretty, that has the smell of disgust. The decay smell is the smell of disgust. That's the quintessential disgusting smell.
首先是这样。很少有人对芦笋感到恶心。他们可能不喜欢它，但他们不会称它为恶心。许多印度人对肉类反感。他们当中有数亿人是素食者。所以文化内部肯定存在差异。一个问题是，某些恶心的东西变得非常受欢迎。例如，在美国，许多人（并非全部）喜欢味道难闻的奶酪，那其实是腐烂的牛奶。而且那相当，带有恶心的气味。腐烂的气味就是恶心的气味。那是典型的恶心气味。
And other people from other cultures can't believe we eat that. But on the other hand, in Southeast Asia, most of their food is seasoned with fermented fish sauce, which smells rotten, and they love that. And most of that, many other people can't. imagine why they'd eat that or rotten eggs or even high meat. So cultures take a very small subset of all the foods they can eat, and they actually make them rotten and disgusting to most people. Little kids will eat them, of course, babies because they don't know about disgust yet.
而来自其他文化的人简直无法相信我们吃那东西。但另一方面，在东南亚，他们的大多数食物都用发酵的鱼露调味，闻起来像腐烂的，而他们非常喜欢那个。而且大多数人，许多其他人无法想象他们为什么会吃那个，或者腐烂的鸡蛋，甚至是高味肉（熟成过度的肉）。因此，各文化从他们能吃的所有食物中挑出极小的一部分，实际上把它们变得对大多数人都腐烂且恶心。小孩子当然会吃它们，婴儿因为还不知道什么是恶心。
Kids have to learn to like those things. After they've learned not to eat feces and anything that smells like that, we say, well, whoa, whoa, this cheese is a little bit like that, but, you know, it's great. So if you become an adult, then it becomes that much harder to eat something like marmite, for example, which I think is disgusting. Marmite or vegamite, they're both the same thing. They're not animal products. The question is whether you will, let's take a food that you really like and put a little drop of marmite. You won't taste it, tiny amount.
孩子们必须学会喜欢这些东西。在他们学会不吃粪便和任何有那种气味的东西之后，我们就会说：“哇，哇，这奶酪有点像那个，但是，你知道，它很棒。”所以如果你长大了，那么要吃像马麦酱（Marmite）这样的东西就会变得更加困难，例如，我觉得马麦酱很恶心。马麦酱或维吉麦酱（Vegemite），它们基本上是一回事。它们不是动物产品。问题在于你是否会——让我们拿一种你真正喜欢的食物，在里面滴一小滴马麦酱。你不会尝出来，极少量的。
When you eat it, people will say, sure, it's not like a cockroach. So it doesn't have that disgust quality to it. And almost everything that has that quality is an animal product. And animals are, of course, are highly nutritious, highly favorite food. And we've gone to great difficulty, to disguise that, particularly in the United States. In Europe, you know, you'll see in the market animal carcasses hanging up, or the fur will be on rabbit meat when they sell it. But in the United States, we wrap it in plastic.
当你吃它时，人们会说，当然，它不像蟑螂。所以它没有那种令人恶心的特质。而几乎所有具备这种特质的东西都是动物产品。动物当然是营养丰富、备受喜爱的食物。我们付出了巨大的努力来掩饰这一点，尤其是在美国。在欧洲，你知道，你会在市场上看到悬挂的动物胴体，或者他们卖兔肉时兔毛还留在上面。但在美国，我们用塑料把它包起来。
You don't have any idea where it's from. We don't do that with fish. you can buy a whole fish very easily. And some people are put off by that. And if you share them a whole fish in a restaurant, they'll be put off. But other people have no trouble with that. As I say, we get used to discuss. How wide is the range of disgust sensitivity?
你根本不知道它来自哪里。我们对鱼可不这样。你可以非常轻松地买到整条鱼。有些人对此感到反感。如果你在餐馆里给他们看整条鱼，他们会感到反感。但其他人对此完全没有问题。正如我所说，我们习惯了恶心。恶心敏感度的范围有多广？
Why are some people so much more easily disgusted than others? First of all, there is an enormous range. Let me just give you an example. Some people will have no trouble eating rotten things and any kind of meat, raw meat, things like that. And they're not upset about body waste. They don't like them, but they don't get upset about it. Other people, for example, would not blow their nose
为什么有些人比其他人更容易感到恶心？首先，这个范围非常巨大。我举个例子。有些人吃腐烂的东西和各种肉类（生肉之类的）毫无问题。而且他们对身体排泄物并不感到不安。他们不喜欢它们，但不会为此感到心烦意乱。而另一些人，例如，甚至不会用一张崭新的卫生纸擤鼻涕，这可以说是相当敏感了，对吧？
in a brand new piece of toilet paper, which is pretty sensitive, right? So you have this enormous range of sensitivity discussed. But we don't know why this is true. We can see there's some genetic component, in some early environment, but a lot of the variation we say can't be explained in anything and liking dogs and what kinds of things that people do. Might it be that somebody has a more acute sense of smell and taste and that that person
所以你拥有如此巨大的恶心敏感度范围。但我们不知道为什么会这样。我们可以看到其中有一些基因成分、一些早期的环境因素，但我们发现很多变异无法用任何东西来解释，比如喜欢狗以及人们所做的各种事情。会不会是因为某人拥有更敏锐的嗅觉和味觉，从而导致这个人
would be more easily disgusted? Has that been looked at? There's no evidence that that's true. Just as you wouldn't say that an artist like Picasso, did Picasso have very good eyesight? Probably not. And this is the same thing with disgusted. You might be able to detect a decay odor in the refrigerator, say, more rapidly than anyone else.
更容易感到恶心？有人研究过这一点吗？没有证据表明这是真的。就像你不会说像毕加索这样的艺术家——毕加索的视力非常好吗？可能并非如此。这与恶心感是一样的。你可能比任何人都更快地检测到冰箱里的腐烂气味，比如说。
But whether it bothers you or not is another matter. It's not the detection. It's how much it upsets you. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining. signing set for only $499. This Memorial Day, get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot.
但它是否困扰你是另一回事。关键不在于检测，而在于它让你感到多么心烦意乱。家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销让你的夏天现在就开始。是时候用 Nextgrill 四火眼燃气烤炉点燃夏日烧烤了，特价仅售 199 美元。并以仅售 499 美元的汉普顿湾西格罗夫七件套户外餐饮桌椅组合，在整个季节招待亲友。在这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。
While supplies last, price is invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See homedepot.com slash price match for details. In many ways, it feels like we're more removed from disgusting things today than we used to be. I mean, we have indoor plumbing and we don't have to, most of us don't have to kill our own food. Do you think that we have a lower disgust tolerance as a species as a result of this? it's probably true that we've been protected from disgusting things. On the other hand, you could say, if you're exposed to a lot of disgust early, you might get more tolerance of it.
售完即止，价格有效期限为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，适用除外条款。详情请访问 homedepot.com 穿越南北价格匹配页面（homedepot.com slash price match）。在许多方面，感觉我们今天比过去离恶心的东西更远了。我的意思是，我们有室内水管设施，而且我们不必——我们大多数人不必自己宰杀食物。你认为作为人类物种，我们的恶心耐受力因此变低了吗？这很可能是真的，我们一直受到保护，免受恶心事物的侵害。另一方面，你可以说，如果你早期接触了大量的恶心事物，你可能会对它有更高的耐受力。
So there's every reason to believe that we've had less experience with disgusting things than people a hundred years ago. No question because of all things you mentioned, the plumbing and so on. But the question is whether that makes you more or less sensitive to discuss is another question. because you can become adapted to it or you can become sensitized to it. We don't know, those are two opposite processes. When you're exposed to something like with an allergen, you get sensitized to it. Right.
所以有充分的理由相信，与一百年前的人相比，我们对恶心事物的经历更少。毫无疑问，因为你提到的所有事情，管道设施等等。但这是否会让你对恶心更敏感或更不敏感，则是另一个问题。因为你可以对它适应，也可以对它敏感化。我们不知道，这是两个相反的过程。当你接触某种东西时，就像对过敏原一样，你会对它敏感化。没错。
The exposure makes you more sense. There are lots of things that we learn to pay no attention to because we get adapted to them. So you can't always tell when someone's exposed to something, whether they're going to be traumatized or they're going to be traumatized or they're going to to get used to it. Now, what got you interested in the topic to begin with, and why have you stuck with it for so many years? I was working on human food choice, starting in the late 1970s, but I wasn't working on disgust. One of the things I got interested in was meat, because it's such a favorite food of man, of humans.
接触会让你更敏感。有很多事情我们学会了不去理会，因为我们已经适应了它们。所以你不能总是判断当某人接触某事时，他们是会受到创伤，还是会习惯它。现在，最初是什么让你对这个话题感兴趣的，为什么你多年来一直坚持研究它？我从 20 世纪 70 年代末开始研究人类的食物选择，但我当时并没有研究恶心。我感兴趣的事情之一是肉类，因为它是人类非常喜爱的食物。
And then I discovered that, isn't it interesting, that almost all the taboos of food are about animal products. And then I started looking at that and I realized that many of the taboos were associated with disgust but people didn't want to, they got nauseous and thinking about them. They didn't want to have anything to do with them. They'd get upset up.
然后我发现，这难道不有趣吗，几乎所有的食物禁忌都与动物产品有关。然后我开始研究这个，我意识到许多禁忌都与恶心有关，但人们不愿意——他们在想到这些时会感到恶心。他们不想与它们有任何瓜葛。他们会感到心烦意乱。
Other people were eating them in their presence. Nobody who hates asparagus has a problem with the person across the table eating asparagus. So this was a very powerful thing. And I realized it was one of the most powerful reactions that people have to anything, not just food.
当别人在他们面前吃这些东西时，他们会感到不安。讨厌芦笋的人绝不会对坐在餐桌对面的人吃芦笋感到有问题。所以这是一个非常强大的反应。我意识到这是人类对任何事物（不仅仅是食物）的最强烈反应之一。
It's so powerful, as I said, that if it touches something you love, it spoils it. So that's what got me into the disgust. It was starting out with meat. The fact that we experienced disgust as much as universally as we do, I think, could be deleterious to us going forward in terms of water. I mean, we are in a situation where at some point in the not too distant future, they're going to be parts of the country and if not the world where people don't have enough water. And yet, it's very easy to recycle human waste. I mean, we can recycle human waste within seconds and make it drinkable. Why is that such a difficult thing to overcome?
正如我所说，它是如此强大，以至于如果它接触到你喜爱的东西，它就会毁了它。这就是我涉足恶心研究的原因。它是从肉类开始的。我认为，我们像现在这样普遍地体验到恶心，从水资源的角度来看，可能会对我们的未来产生不利影响。我的意思是，我们正处于这样一种境遇中：在不远的将来的某个时刻，国家甚至世界的某些地方，人们将没有足够的水。然而，回收人类排泄物是非常容易的。我的意思是，我们可以在几秒钟内回收人类排泄物并使其达到可饮用水的标准。为什么克服这一点会如此困难？
I mean, in fact, aren't we all essentially drinking dinosaur pee anyway? Well, one of my colleagues calculated for me, a geologist, that everyone in Europe who takes a glass of water are drinking a few molecules that went through Adolf Hitler. Now, Adolf Hitler is a great contaminant. People don't want anything to do with it. So what happens is all of our water that we drink is contaminated because it's been in toilets and all sorts of things. And yeah, it goes down streams and it gets processed.
我的意思是，事实上，难道我们本质上不都在喝恐龙尿吗？嗯，我的一个地质学家同事为我计算过，欧洲每个喝一杯水的人，都在喝曾经流经阿道夫·希特勒身体的几个水分子。现在，阿道夫·希特勒是一个巨大的污染源。人们不想与他有任何关系。所以发生的情况是，我们喝的所有水都被污染了，因为它曾流经马桶和各种各样的地方。是的，它流过小溪并得到了处理。
But there's still molecules of water in there that were in very bad place. So we get used to that. We just don't think about it. Now, if you happen to go to visit a sewer plant, it might put you off for a while because you have in your mind the origin of the water. But of course, it's very important to drink water. and if we were put off by disgusted water, we would be in very bad shape.
但其中仍然含有曾处于非常糟糕地方的水分子。所以我们习惯了这一点。我们只是不去想它。现在，如果你恰好去参观一个污水处理厂，它可能会让你反感一段时间，因为你的脑海里存留着水的来源。但当然，喝水是非常重要的。如果我们对带有恶心感的水感到反感，我们的处境就会非常糟糕。
So what we do is we don't think about it, but the movement to purify water, to solve the water problem by taking fouled water and reprocessing it into pure water. It's safe of water than the water that comes into your faucet now. People are very put off by it because that's a bad image, and they think of it that way. They think it reminds them that water is sewage process.
所以我们做的是不去想它，但净化水运动——通过收集污水并将其重新加工成纯净水来解决水资源问题——这比你现在水龙头里流出的水还要安全。人们对此非常反感，因为那是一个不好的意象，他们就是这样想的。他们认为这让他们想起水是经过处理的污水。
Now, Singapore has been a leader in this area because they are short of water and they've had to recycle water. And what they've done is a very good job of convincing people that it's okay. They have a facility of water purification facility that you can visit. You can get bottles of bott, you can get bottled water made from it. They'll provide it to you for your parties and so on. It tastes fine, of course. And they've done a good job of selling it, and they mix it with their groundwater.
现在，新加坡在这个领域一直处于领先地位，因为他们缺水，不得不回收水。他们所做的是非常出色地让人们相信这是可以接受的。他们有一个水净化设施，你可以去参观。你可以买到用它制成的瓶装水。他们会在你的派对上为你提供这种水等等。当然，它尝起来很好。他们很好地推销了它，并把它与他们的地下水混合。
They don't actually go right from the purification. They don't have enough groundwater, but they have some. So they've done a good job of selling it, and in Southern California where there's a water shortage, there have been some cases where it's gotten acceptable. But it takes some work because the people who are opposed to it, who are opposed to this process. They have sayings like, you know.
他们实际上并不是直接来自净化过程。他们的地下水虽然不够，但还是有一些。所以他们很好地推销了它，在水资源短缺的南加州，也出现了一些它被接受的情况。但这需要一些工作，因为那些反对它的人，那些反对这个过程的人。他们有这样的口号，你知道的。
Oh, toilet to tap. Telet to tap, yes, toilet to tap. That's the one. And so they push it in your face and then they can sue. And in our country, you know, you can sue and stop anything for a while. So this has happened. But for the public health point of view, producing purified water from sewage is a very positive thing. And disgust gets in the way of it a little.
哦，从马桶到水龙头。从马桶到水龙头，是的，从马桶到水龙头。就是那个。所以他们把它推到你面前，然后他们可以起诉。在我国，你知道，你可以起诉并阻止任何事情一段时间。所以这种情况发生了。但从公共卫生角度来看，从污水中生产净化水是一件非常积极的事情。而恶心感在一定程度上阻碍了这一点。
So it sounds like a marketing problem. Yes. What is the answer? I mean, how can we get people to get over that disgust factor so that, you know, I mean, this is about public health, right? Well, it's interesting that reason doesn't work very well with disgust, explaining to people that it's not really disgusting. When we drop a cockroach into juice and people won't drink it, we say, then why won't you drink it? And they say, well, cockroach is about disease vectors, you know, I can get this. We say, okay, we'll do it with a sterilized cockroach. This cockroach. you're safer than you're for. So we put it in, we take it out, and I still don't want it.
听起来这像是个营销问题。是的。答案是什么？我的意思是，我们怎样才能让人们克服这种恶心因素，以便，你知道，我的意思是，这关乎公共卫生，对吧？嗯，有趣的是，理性在面对恶心时并不能很好地起作用，向人们解释它其实并不恶心。当我们把一只蟑螂丢进果汁里，人们不肯喝时，我们就会问：“那你为什么不喝呢？”他们会说：“嗯，蟑螂是疾病媒介，你知道的，我会染病。”我们说：“好吧，我们用一只灭菌的蟑螂来做。”这只蟑螂比你想象的还要安全。所以我们把它放进去，然后拿出来，而他们还是不想要它。
So we have a situation where reasoning with people doesn't help. The best thing is exposure. If you get exposed to something that's mildly disgusting, not terribly disgusting to start with, you get used to it, and then you don't pay any attention to it. And that's certainly true with water. And I think it's also true with insects,
所以我们遇到了这样一种情况：和人们讲道理是没有用的。最好的办法是接触。如果你接触某种轻微恶心、一开始并不是极其恶心的东西，你就会习惯它，然后你就会不再理会它。水确实如此。我想昆虫也是如此，
something else I've discovered. Insects are a very good source of food, and they're inexpensive and they benefit for sustainability and they don't come with a killing problem. Most people don't mind killing mealworms, you know, or something like that. So the main thing is to get people to try them and then try them a little more and then get used to them because that's a powerful way of doing things.
这是我发现的另一件事。昆虫是非常好的食物来源，它们价格便宜，有利于可持续发展，而且不会带来杀戮的问题。大多数人并不介意杀死黄粉虫，你知道，或者类似的东西。所以最主要的事情是让人尝试它们，然后再多尝试一点，然后习惯它们，因为这是一种有力的方法。
Is it in some sense the idea that they came out of the dirt in addition to that? I mean, but all animals at some point are, you know, in something dirty. You can make stories about this. I mean, people think pigs of sort of dirty animals because they eat garbage. Cows don't eat garbage, but people are very happy to eat pork, not Orthodox Jews, but most people. It's very hard to figure out why some animals are more disgusting than others. It is true that they have slimy habits or if they're carnivores.
在某种意义上，是不是因为它们除了那些之外还来自于泥土？我的意思是，但所有动物在某个时刻都，你知道，身处某种肮脏的环境中。你可以为此编造故事。我的意思是，人们认为猪是那种肮脏的动物，因为它们吃垃圾。牛不吃垃圾，但人们非常乐意吃猪肉，正统犹太人除外，但大多数人如此。很难弄清楚为什么某些动物比其他动物更令人恶心。确实，它们有黏糊糊的习惯，或者如果它们是食肉动物。
We tend not to like to eat carnivores, like cats or dogs. That's maybe because they eat meat. and they also have much more putrid feces. You know, elephant dung or cow dung is not that smelly, less disgusting than leopard dung. So there are a lot of things going on there. There's a lot of people interested in, but no one's gotten too far on why certain animals are eaten and others are not. Why is it that a lot of people like really gross humor? I mean, you know, every little kid and a lot of adults will laugh at poop jokes, but what's the connection?
我们倾向于不喜欢吃食肉动物，比如猫或狗。这可能是因为它们吃肉。而且它们的粪便也具有更强的恶臭。你知道，大象粪或牛粪没有那么臭，比豹子的粪便更不恶心。所以这里有很多因素在起作用。有很多人对此感兴趣，但对于为什么某些动物被食用而另一些不被食用，没有人研究得太深入。为什么许多人都喜欢非常恶俗的幽默？我的意思是，你知道，每个小孩子和许多成年人都会对便便笑话开怀大笑，但它们之间有什么联系？
between disgust and humor? There is a big connection. Everyone who's out a little boy knows that little boys love to gross out their parents and gross out little girls. Anyway, so, yeah, it is a source of humor. I think it's part of a much bigger picture that humans get a lot of pleasure
恶心与幽默之间有什么联系？它们之间有着巨大的联系。任何带过小男孩的人都知道，小男孩喜欢恶心他们的父母，也喜欢恶心小女孩。总之，是的，它是幽默的源泉。我认为这是更大格局的一部分，人类从做事情和享受那些最初是负面的事情中获得了很多快乐。
out of doing things and enjoying them that are originally negative. So they'd like to go down roller coasters because their body thinks that they're going to drop into their death, but they know they're not. There's something pleasant about experiencing something negative but knowing it's not really threatening.
所以他们喜欢坐过山车，因为他们的身体认为他们要坠入深渊而死，但他们知道自己不会。体验负面的事情但知道它并不是真正的威胁，这其中有一种令人愉快的感觉。
So poop jokes are not threatening to you. You're not experiencing it directly. So if you're walking down the street and someone in a tux and partners in a gown going to an event and they step in dog do, that's sort of funny. But if you step in dog do, it's not funny. So the defense of, I call it benign masochism, being safe, a feeling that you experience
所以便便笑话对你没有威胁。你不是直接在体验它。所以如果你走在街上，看到一个穿着燕尾服、伴侣穿着礼服去参加活动的人踩到了狗屎，那挺好笑的。但如果你自己踩到了狗屎，那就不好笑了。所以我称之为“良性受虐”（benign masochism）的防御机制，即处于安全状态、感受到你体验到
something negative and your body is telling you get out of here, but you know that it's really okay. And there's a certain pleasure in that. And I think that's partly what's going on with disgust humor. Well, we've talked about how disgust may have started as a way to keep ourselves from eating on safe foods. But now we use the term a lot more broadly. We will talk about being disgusted by a person's selfish behavior, for example.
某种负面的东西，而你的身体在告诉你“离开这里”，但你知道其实一切都好。这其中有一种确定的快乐。我想这正是恶心幽默中部分发生的事情。好吧，我们已经讨论了恶心感最初可能是作为一种让我们避免食用不安全食物的方式开始的。但现在我们更广泛地使用这个词。例如，我们会谈到对一个人自私的行为感到恶心。
Is that the same kind of disgust that we feel viscerally when we see something like poop? Well, it's a big discussion in the literature now as to whether what we call moral disgust is really just a name disgust attached to it or it really involves a similar reaction. So some people will make disgust faces when they hear about certain kinds of crimes, particularly bodily crimes like murder. The big issue is, are all moral events, immoral events disgusting? The answer seems to be no. It's only a certain subset of them. That subset that has to do with body and purity. So people might say that, for example, using a crucifix as a doorstop is disgusting.
这与我们看到像便便这样的东西时本能感受到的恶心是同一种恶心吗？嗯，现在文献中关于我们所谓的道德恶心究竟只是贴上了恶心的标签，还是真的涉及类似反应，有着很大的讨论。所以有些人听到某些类型的犯罪，特别是像谋杀这样的身体犯罪时，会做出恶心的表情。重大问题在于：所有的道德事件、不道德事件都是令人恶心的吗？答案似乎是否定的。只有其中的一部分。那一部分与身体和纯洁有关。所以人们可能会说，例如，把十字架当作门档是令人恶心的。
Because that's a violation of what Richard Schuader calls the ethics of divinity. There's certain things that are sacred and you don't defile them. And that's the kind of thing that is discussed. Other people think it's more about bodily things, like being slashed or murdered or, you know, cannibalism. But it is clear that in some cases of moral disgust, people do seem to feel nauseous. Incess is a great example. people tend to feel nauseous about an insect,
因为那是对理查德·施韦德（Richard Shweder）所谓的“神圣伦理”的侵犯。有些事情是神圣的，你不能亵渎它们。这就是那种会被认为恶心的东西。其他人则认为它更多地关乎身体方面，比如被砍伤或谋杀，或者，你知道，同类相食。但很明显，在某些道德恶心的情况下，人们似乎确实会感到恶心。乱伦就是一个很好的例子。人们往往对昆虫感到恶心，
but that's not true for things like theft. There's a bloodless crimes. So it looks like anger is the emotion that's mostly involved in most, what we call immoral behavior, but there's a subset of it having to do with bodies or divinity, we might call, which is disgust-related. That subset is much less in the United States than say in Hindu India, where divinity is a major issue, sacredness of food, a very big issue.
但对于诸如盗窃之类的事情并非如此。那是无血的犯罪。所以看起来愤怒是我们所谓的多数不道德行为中主要涉及的情绪，但其中与身体或神圣有关的那一部分——我们或许可以称之为——是与恶心相关的。在美国，这一部分比在印度教盛行的印度要少得多，在印度，神圣性是一个主要问题，食物的神圣性是一个非常大的问题。
But in the United States, we limit that. And most of our laws and crimes are about harming other people. Most of the moral violations that disgusts involvement don't necessarily harm other people. For example, burning the American flag doesn't really harm any other people. But it's a divinity violation. It's disgusting. Disgusting in public. loosely to mean bad.
但在美国，我们限制了这一点。我们的大多数法律和罪行都是关于伤害他人的。涉及恶心的大多数道德违规行为并不一定会伤害他人。例如，焚烧美国国旗并没有真正伤害任何人。但这是对神圣性的违背。这是恶心的。在公众当中，松散地用“恶心”来表示“坏”。
You say, that's disgusting. You say, I heard that so-and-so does something minor. I don't go. Cheats on their income tax regularly. And, oh, that's disgusting. But that says the very loose use of the word, where you're just saying bad. And so one of the problems is you have to distinguish the use of the word disgust to mean bad to discuss in a more narrow, interesting sense.
你会说：“真恶心。”你会说：“我听说某某人做了某件小事。”我不会去。经常在所得税上作弊。然后，“哦，真恶心。”但这只是这个词非常松散的用法，你只是在说“坏”。所以问题之一在于，你必须将用来表示“坏”的“恶心”一词的用法，与更狭义、更有趣意义上的“恶心”区分开来。
So what are the big questions that remain to be answered? about disgust. Are you still doing research in this area? And what would you like to know that you don't know yet? Well, first of all, my own research, I've gotten out of most discussed research. And the reason is it's become very popular. I like to work on things that not many people are working on. And disgust is a hot subject now. So I'd have to read too many things to be able to do my research. I am interested in one feature of disgust, which not many people are interested in, which is contagion. the idea that disgusting things are contaminating. What does it mean that the juice that a cockroach was dipped into is now bad?
那么，还有哪些有待解答的重大问题关于恶心？你还在这个领域做研究吗？你还有什么想知道而现在还不知道的吗？嗯，首先，我自己的研究，我已经退出了绝大多数恶心研究。原因在于它变得非常受欢迎。我喜欢研究没有多少人在做的事情。而现在恶心感是一个热门课题。所以我必须阅读太多的东西才能开展我的研究。我对恶心的某一个特征很感兴趣，没有多少人对此感兴趣，那就是传染性。也就是说，令人恶心的事情具有污染性。蟑螂浸泡过的果汁现在变坏了，这意味着什么？
What is it in your mind that has happened to that juice? Essentially, it's cockroachness has entered that juice, just like Hitler has entered his sweater, even after you launder it. So I'm interested in what the thoughts are, that what is it this stuff that comes in? Some of it's like germs, which is, of course, the origin of disgust. but others are not a thing. So, for example, you can do anything you want to hit the sweater and people don't want to wear it.
在你的脑海里，那果汁发生了什么？本质上，蟑螂的特质已经进入了那个果汁，就像希特勒进入了他的毛衣一样，即使在你洗涤它之后也是如此。所以我对人们的想法很感兴趣，究竟是什么东西进入了其中？其中有些类似于微生物，当然这正是恶心的起源。但有些则不是实体。所以，例如，你可以对希特勒的毛衣做任何你想做的事，人们还是不想穿它。
You can kill all the germs in it, you can wash it and wash it and wash it. So there's something more spiritual in people's head that enters from Hitler that is not washable. And I'm interested in that sort of thing. That's an issue in disgust, but the biggest issue in discussed now is what first issue is one of the brain mechanisms of it. And what's interesting about that is it's very easy, to get people disgusted. It's much easier to get people disgusted than to get them angry.
你可以杀死里面所有的细菌，你可以一遍又一遍地清洗它。所以人们脑海中有一种更深层、源自希特勒的东西是洗不掉的。我对这种事情很感兴趣。这是一个关于厌恶的问题，但目前讨论的最大问题是，它的首要问题之一是大脑的运作机制。有趣的是，让人产生厌恶感非常容易。让人产生厌恶感比让人生气容易得多。
So if they're in a scanner, for example, all I have to think of is a piece of dog poop on a plate and they're disgusted. You can't get them really angry so easily. So it's been a very good tool to study how people react to emotions. The other big issue is what moral disgust is. Is it really the same kind of thing as disgust? It's the same thing. It's the same thing. system that's involved, or is it really just the word discussed that's tagged on to these things? Dr. Rosson, I want to thank you for joining me today. I think we had a perfectly disgusting conversation. Okay, good. Well, thanks a nice talking to you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org
因此，举例来说，如果他们躺在扫描仪里，我只需要让他们想象盘子里有一块狗屎，他们就会感到恶心。你没法那么轻易地让他们真正生气。所以这一直是研究人们如何对情绪做出反应的极好工具。另一个重大问题是什么是道德厌恶。这真的和那种厌恶是一回事吗？是一样的。参与其中的系统是一样的，还是说“厌恶”这个词只是被贴在了这些事情上？罗森博士，我想感谢你今天能来。我觉得我们进行了一次非常“令人反感”的对话。好的，很好。很高兴和你交谈。您可以在我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org 上找到往期的《心理学热线》节目
or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. For those of you who want to know more about psychology and the work of APA, you can join us as a supporter. You don't have to be a psychologist. The benefits include a subscription to our award-winning magazine, monitor on psychology, as well as discounts on our books and other publications. So if psychology is your passion, or if you just want to know more about the science, you can become a supporter by visiting at.a.a.org slash speaking. That's at.a.a.a.org slash speaking. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 以及您获取播客的任何地方收听。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请订阅并给我们留下评价。对于那些想要更多了解心理学和美国心理学协会（APA）工作的人，您可以加入我们成为支持者。您不需要成为一名心理学家。福利包括订阅我们屡获殊荣的杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology），以及购买我们的书籍和其他出版物时的折扣。因此，如果心理学是您的热情所在，或者您只是想更多地了解这门科学，您可以访问 apa.org/speaking 成为支持者。网址是 apa.org/speaking。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes. so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学热线》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢您收听美国心理学协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。放松身心，本周的杂货采购就交给Ralph's送货服务吧。我们只挑选最新鲜的物品，然后核对您的购物清单并精心挑选每一件商品。接着我们会将它们全部打包，最快30分钟内送达，让您确信这就是您订购的商品。通过Ralph's的送货和自提服务，以您的方式享受新鲜杂货。现在，您的第一笔送货或自提订单还可以省下20美元。Ralph's，为每个人保持新鲜。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。